les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 hasta ahora 207
sitios culturales han sido dañados en
Ucrania desde que empezó la invasión
rusa el 24 de febrero esta cifra viene
de la unescola agencia de Naciones
Unidas encargada de la cultura que
empezó a utilizar imágenes de satélite
para supervisar la destrucción de bienes
y patrimonio cultural infligida por la
guerra se trata de un experimento piloto
con la ambición de poder en el futuro
utilizar esta herramienta a nivel
mundial y que se inscribe en un trabajo
más global y concreto de documentación
de este conflicto histórico como lo
explica la directora de la entidad
cultural y situaciones de emergencia de
la UNESCO
nuestra principal responsabilidad es
asegurarnos de que disponemos de
información sobre la situación de los
lugares para estar preparados para la
recuperación
Pero sabemos que en circunstancias
anteriores esta documentación ha sido
utilizada también por las autoridades
del país si quieren investigar
acusaciones de crímenes de guerra
en otras noticias culturales el mundo de
la pintura dijo Adiós al maestro del
negro y de la luz sea su like explicaba
que le gustaba la autoridad del negro su
gravedad su evidencia su radicalidad
conocido por sus infinitas tonalidades
de negro y sus juegos con las texturas
el pintor y grabador era considerado
como uno de los artistas más importantes
de Francia y logró ser el artista vivo
más cotizado de su país que a su Latch
falleció el 26 de octubre a los 72 años
vamos ahora del lado de Cuba donde el
Festival Internacional de ballet de La
Habana hace un regreso triunfal después
de cuatro años de ausencia por la
pandemia de Kobe 19 se celebrará cada
dos años desde su fundación en
1960 por la leyenda del baile Alicia
Alonso que falleció en 2019 el público
podrá admirar los artistas y las
campañas nacionales e internacionales
hasta el 13 de noviembre la primera
bailarina del ballet nacional de Cuba
Gretel morejón nos compartió su alegría
en los festivales de valencia siempre
para nosotros para la compañía y los
bailarines es como una fiesta en esta
ocasión es especial pues estuvimos mucho
tiempo por la pandemia sin primero sin
bailar y después sin festival
son muchas horas de trabajo muchas horas
de preparación llevamos meses preparando
lo que vamos a hacer en el escenario
pero siempre cuando llegas una alegría
sobre todo te reencuentras con
bailarines de otros de otros países con
maestros que vienen justamente para esta
ocasión
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y en Francia el festival linier celebró
su edición número 14 en Lyon la ciudad
donde nació el cine con los Hermanos
el punto culminante de esta edición fue
sin duda cuando Tim Burton recibió el
premio linier 2022 un galardón que
recompensa una destacada contribución a
la historia del cine y que conmovió
especialmente al muy famoso director
guionista y productor estadounidense
conocido por sus películas excéntricas
lo escuchamos
es un gran honor estar en la cuna del
cine
he recibido esta noche una gran recarga
es tan bonito es tan hermoso
es el festival más bonito y sencillo en
el que Estados Unidos
en el sentido de que todo gira en torno
al amor y a la alegría de las películas
Así que para mí es como Honestamente
puedo decir que nunca había sentido
tanto En ningún lugar Así que estoy un
poco sin palabras pero muchas gracias
Nunca olvidaré esto
cerramos Este programa con los estrenos
musicales que nos llamaron la atención
esta semana empezando con el nuevo álbum
de La puertorriqueña y le un tercer
disco que la cantautora llamó nakarrile
y que trata de sus temas de predilección
que son el amor el feminismo y el
colonialismo con la ayuda de voces
invitadas en numerosas colaboraciones
Mon laferte Natalia Lafourcade Ivy Queen
o el español Rodrigo Cuevas como en este
tema cuando te miro
sobre mi
frente
el francés también estrenó un álbum
transparente el segundo proyecto de este
artista de 21 años que sigue su ascenso
en la escena del Rap francés
[Música]
de la profesión había estar presentó la
versión deluxe de su primer álbum 19 y
dangerous con el estreno de la canción
inédita running al lado del cantante y
productor low Jane
[Música]
Nos despedimos con otro artista
nigeriano ox la de estreno al videoclip
de su tema curiosa que conquistó el
mundo en con su melodía cautivadora
Gracias a ustedes por su confianza y
sigan con nosotros hay más cultura en
francés 24.com
[Música]